qui menacent notre liberté et notre dignité dans un avenir proche
sont développées par des entreprises
dans le domaine de l'enregistrement et de la vente
de nos données et notre attention
à des publicitaires et autres :
Facebook, Google, Amazon,
Alibaba, Tencent.
L'intelligence artificielle a également commencé à stimuler leur marché.
On pourrait croire que l'intelligence artificielle
sera la suite des publicités en ligne.
Ce n'est pas le cas.
C'est un saut dans la catégorie.
C'est un monde complètement différent
qui a un énorme potentiel.
Ça pourrait accélérer notre compréhension
de nombreux domaines d'étude et de recherche.
Pour paraphraser un célèbre philosophe hollywoodien :
« Un grand pouvoir implique de grandes responsabilités. »
Considérons un fait fondamental de nos vies numériques : les publicités.
Nous les ignorons.
Elles semblent grossières, inefficaces.
Nous avons tous été suivis sur internet
par une pub basée sur une chose que nous avions cherchée ou lue.
Vous cherchez un paire de bottes
et pendant une semaine, ces bottes vous suivent partout où vous allez.
Même après avoir succombé et les avoir achetées,
elles vous suivent encore.
Nous sommes un peu protégés contre cette manipulation bon marché.
Nous levons les yeux au ciel et pensons : « Ça ne marche pas. »
Mis à part qu'en ligne,
les technologies numériques ne sont pas que des publicités.
Pour le comprendre, réfléchissons à un exemple du monde physique.
Vous savez comment à la caisse au supermarché, près du caissier,
il y a des bonbons et chewing-gums à hauteur des yeux des enfants ?
C'est conçu pour les faire pleurnicher auprès de leurs parents
alors que les parents sont sur le point de payer.
C'est une architecture de persuasion.
Ce n'est pas sympa, mais ça marche.
C'est pourquoi vous le voyez partout.
Dans le monde physique,
de telles architectures de persuasion sont limitées
car on ne peut mettre qu'un certain nombre de choses près de la caisse.
Les bonbons et chewing-gums sont les mêmes pour tout le monde,
même si ça fonctionne
surtout pour les gens ayant des petits êtres pleurnichant à leurs côtés.
Dans le monde physique, nous vivons avec ces limites.
Dans le monde numérique cependant,
les architectures de persuasion peuvent être adaptées
pour des milliards de personnes,
elles peuvent cibler, déduire, comprendre
et être déployées pour des individus,
un par un,
en déterminant nos faiblesses
et elles peuvent être envoyées sur l'écran privé des téléphones
afin que ce ne soit pas visible à nos yeux.
C'est différent.
Ce n'est qu'une chose basique dont est capable l'intelligence artificielle.
Prenons un exemple.
Vous voulez vendre des billets d'avion pour Las Vegas.
Dans l'ancien monde, vous pensiez à des segments démographiques à cibler
d'après votre expérience et ce que vous pouvez imaginer.
Vous pourriez faire de la publicité
aux hommes ayant entre 25 et 35 ans
ou aux gens qui ont une limite élevée sur leur carte de crédit
ou aux couples à la retraite.
C'est ce que vous auriez fait.
Avec le big data et l'apprentissage des machines,
ça ne marche plus comme ça.
Pour l'imaginer,
pensez à toutes les données que Facebook a sur vous :
tous les status tapés,
toutes les conversations Messenger,
tous vos lieux de connexion,
toutes les photos que vous avez téléchargées.
Si vous tapez quelque chose, changez d'avis et le supprimez,
Facebook le garde et l'analyse également.
De plus en plus, il essaye de vous relier à vos données hors ligne.
Il achète également des données auprès de courtiers de données.
Ce pourrait être n'importe quoi, de vos documents financiers
à votre historique de recherche.
Aux Etats-Unis, de telles données sont systématiquement collectées,
comparées et vendues.
En Europe, les règles sont plus strictes.
Ce qu'il se passe alors c'est que,
en fouillant toutes ces données,
ces algorithmes d'apprentissage des machines --
ils sont appelés algorithmes d'apprentissage pour cette raison --
ils apprennent à comprendre les caractéristiques des gens
ayant déjà acheté des billets pour Las Vegas.
Quand ils l'apprennent de données existantes,
ils apprennent aussi comment l'appliquer à de nouvelles personnes.
Face à une nouvelle personne,
ils peuvent classifier
si cette personne a des chances d'acheter un billet pour Las Vegas ou pas.
Bien. Vous vous dites qu'une offre pour acheter des billets pour Las Vegas,
vous pouvez l'ignorer.
Mais le problème n'est pas là.
Le problème,
c'est que nous ne comprenons plus vraiment
comment fonctionnent ces algorithmes complexes.
Nous ne comprenons pas comment ils font cette catégorisation.
Ce sont d'énormes matrices, des milliers de lignes et colonnes,
peut-être même des millions,
et ni les programmeurs,
ni quiconque les regardant,
même avec toutes les données,
ne comprend plus comment ça opère exactement,
pas plus que vous ne sauriez ce que je pense en ce moment
si l'on vous montrait une coupe transversale de mon cerveau.
C'est comme si nous ne programmions plus,
nous élevons une intelligence que nous ne comprenons pas vraiment.
Ces choses fonctionnent seulement s'il y a un énorme volume de données,
elles pourraient donc aussi encourager une surveillance intensifiée à notre égard
afin que les algorithmes d'apprentissage marchent.
C'est pour ça que Facebook veut collecter toutes les données sur vous.
Les algorithmes marchent mieux.
Allons un peu plus loin avec cet exemple de Las Vegas.
Et si le système que nous ne comprenons pas
déterminait qu'il est plus simple de vendre des billets pour Las Vegas
aux gens bipolaires qui sont sur le point d'entrer dans la phase maniaque.
De telles personnes ont tendance à dépenser et parier de façon compulsive.
Ils pourraient le faire, vous ignoreriez que c'était là leur conclusion.
Une fois, j'ai donné cet exemple à quelques informaticiens
et après, l'un d'eux est venu me voir.
Il était préoccupé : « C'est pour ça que je n'ai pas pu le publier ».
J'ai dit : « Publier quoi ? »
Il avait essayé de voir s'il l'on pouvait détecter le début d'une manie
d'après les posts sur les réseaux sociaux avant les symptômes cliniques
et ça avait fonctionné,
ça avait très bien fonctionné,
et il n'avait aucune idée de comment ça marchait ou ce que ça détectait.
Le problème n'est pas résolu s'il ne le publie pas
car il y a déjà des entreprises
qui développent ce genre de technologie
et beaucoup de choses existent déjà.
Ce n'est plus très compliqué.
Vous arrive-t-il d'aller sur YouTube pour regarder une vidéo
et, une heure plus tard, d'en avoir regardées 27 ?
Vous voyez cette colonne que YouTube a sur la droite,
qui dit « A suivre »
et qui se lance automatiquement ?
C'est un algorithme
qui choisit ce qu'il pense qui pourrait vous intéresser
et que vous ne trouveriez pas seul.
Ce n'est pas un humain,
ce sont des algorithmes.
Il considère ce que vous avez regardé et ce que d'autres comme vous ont regardé
et il déduit que ce doit être ce qui vous intéresse,
ce dont vous voulez voir plus
et vous en montre plus.
Ça semble être une fonction bénigne et utile,
mais ça ne l'est pas.
En 2016, j'ai été à des rassemblements du candidat Donald Trump
pour étudier en tant que chercheuse le mouvement le soutenant.
J'étudie les mouvements sociaux, alors j'étudiais ça aussi.
Puis j'ai voulu écrire quelque chose au sujet d'un de ses rassemblements
alors je l'ai regardé sur YouTube.
YouTube a commencé à me recommander
et à lancer automatiquement des vidéos de suprématistes blancs
étant de plus en plus extrémistes.
Si j'en regardais une,
il m'en recommandait une encore plus extrême
et la lançais automatiquement.
Si vous regardez du contenu d'Hillary Clinton ou Bernie Sanders,
YouTube recommande et lance des vidéos gauchistes de conspiration
et plus ça va, plus ça empire.
Vous pensez peut-être que c'est de la politique, mais non.
Il ne s'agit pas de politique.
Ce n'est qu'un algorithme déterminant le comportement humain.
Une fois, j'ai regardé une vidéo sur le végétarisme sur YouTube
et YouTube a recommandé et lancé une vidéo sur le fait d'être végétalien.
Vous n'êtes jamais assez extrême pour YouTube.
(Rires)
Que se passe-t-il ?
L'algorithme de YouTube est propriétaire,
mais voici ce qui, à mon avis, se passe.
L'algorithme a déterminé
que si vous pouvez pousser les gens
à penser que vous pouvez leur montrer quelque chose de plus extrême,
ils ont plus de chances de rester sur le site
à regarder vidéo sur vidéo, descendant dans le terrier du lapin
pendant que Google leur sert des pubs.
Puisque personne ne fait attention à l'éthique du magasin,
ces sites peuvent profiler des gens
comme haïssant les juifs,
pensant que les juifs sont des parasites,
qui ont du contenu anti-sémite très explicite,
et vous laisser les cibler avec des pubs.
Ils peuvent mobiliser les algorithmes
pour trouver des publics similaires,
des gens n'ayant pas de contenu anti-sémite si explicite sur leur profil
mais que les algorithmes détectent comme étant sensibles à de tels messages,
et vous laisser les cibler avec des pubs.
Ça peut sembler être un exemple peu plausible,
mais c'est vrai.
ProPublica a enquêté sur ça
et a découvert que vous pouviez vraiment le faire sur Facebook
et Facebook, serviable, offrait des suggestions
sur comment étendre ce public.
BuzzFeed l'a essayé pour Google et a rapidement découvert
que vous pouvez le faire sur Google.
Ce n'était même pas cher.
Le reporter de ProPublica a dépensé environ 30 dollars
pour cibler cette catégorie.
L'année dernière, le responsable des réseaux sociaux de Donald Trump
a révélé utiliser les dark posts de Facebook pour démobiliser les gens,
pas pour les persuader,
mais pour les convaincre de ne pas voter du tout.
Pour ce faire, ils ont spécifiquement ciblé,
par exemple, les hommes afro-américains dans des villes clés comme Philadelphie
et je vais lire exactement ce qu'il a dit.
Je cite.
Ils utilisaient « des posts non publics
dont la campagne contrôle l'audience
afin que seuls les voient les gens dont nous voulons qu'ils les voient.
Nous l'avons façonné.
Ça affectera considérablement sa capacité à retourner ces gens. »
Qu'y a-t-il dans ces dark posts ?
Nous l'ignorons.
Facebook refuse de le dire.
Facebook arrange également algorithmiquement les posts
que vos amis mettent sur Facebook ou des pages que vous suivez.
Il ne vous montre pas tout chronologiquement.
Il le met dans l'ordre qui, selon l'algorithme, devrait vous pousser
à rester plus longtemps sur le site.
Ça a de nombreuses conséquences.
Vous pensez peut-être que quelqu'un vous ignore sur Facebook.
L'algorithme ne lui montre peut-être jamais vos posts.
L'algorithme en priorise certains et en enterre d'autres.
Des expériences montrent
que ce que l'algorithme choisit de vous montrer
peut influencer vos émotions.
Mais ce n'est pas tout.
Ça influence aussi votre comportement politique.
En 2010, aux élections de mi-mandat,
Facebook a conduit une expérience sur 61 millions de personnes américaines
qui a été révélée après les faits.
Certaines personnes ont vu « Aujourd'hui, c'est jour d'élection »,
le plus simple,
et certaines personnes ont vu celui avec ce petit ajustement
avec les petites photos
de vos amis ayant cliqué sur « j'ai voté ».
Ce simple ajustement.
D'accord ? Les photos étaient la seule modification
et ce post montré qu'une seule fois
a attiré 340 000 électeurs supplémentaires
dans cette élection,
d'après cette recherche
et la liste des électeurs l'a confirmé.
Un hasard ? Non.
Parce qu'en 2012, ils ont reconduit cette même expérience.
A cette époque-là,
ce message civique montré une seule fois
a attiré 270 000 électeurs supplémentaires.
En guise de référence, l'élection présidentielle de 2016
s'est jouée à environ 100 000 votes.
Facebook peut aussi très facilement déduire vos opinions politiques,
même si vous ne les avez pas révélées sur le site.
Ces algorithmes peuvent le faire assez facilement.
Et si une plateforme avec un tel pouvoir
décidait de retourner les partisans d'un candidat pour l'autre ?
Comment le saurions-nous ?
Nous sommes partis de quelque chose semble-t-il inoffensif --
les pubs nous suivant partout en ligne --
et sommes arrivés ailleurs.
En tant que public et citoyens,
nous ne savons plus si nous voyons les mêmes informations
ou ce que voient les autres
et sans base d'informations commune,
peu à peu,
le débat public devient impossible
et nous n'en sommes qu'aux premières phases.
Ces algorithmes peuvent facilement déduire
des choses comme votre ethnie, vos opinions religieuses, politiques,
vos traits de personnalité,
votre intelligence, votre bonheur, votre usage de substances addictives,
la situation maritale de vos parents, votre âge et votre sexe,
uniquement grâce aux « J'aime » de Facebook.
Ces algorithmes peuvent identifier des manifestants
même si leur visage est partiellement caché.
Ces algorithmes peuvent peut-être détecter l'orientation sexuelle des gens
simplement grâce à leur photo de profil sur un site de rencontres.
Ce sont des conjectures statistiques,
ils n'auront pas raison à 100%,
mais je ne vois pas les puissants résister à la tentation d'utiliser ces technologies
simplement parce qu'il y a des faux positifs,
ce qui, bien sûr, créera un couche supplémentaire de problèmes.
Imaginez ce qu'un Etat peut faire
avec l'énorme volume de données qu'il a sur ces citoyens.
La Chine utilise déjà une technologie de détection du visage
pour identifier et arrêter des gens.
Voici la tragédie :
nous instaurons cette infrastructure de surveillance d’autoritarisme
simplement pour que les gens cliquent sur des pubs.
Ce ne sera pas l’autoritarisme d'Orwell.
Ce n'est pas « 1984 ».
Si l'autoritarisme une peur déclarée pour nous terroriser,
nous aurons tous peur mais nous le saurons,
nous détesterons ça et résisterons.
Mais si les gens au pouvoir utilisent ces algorithmes
pour nous surveiller discrètement,
pour nous juger et nous inciter,
pour prédire et identifier les fauteurs de trouble et les rebelles,
pour déployer une architecture de persuasion à grande échelle
et pour manipuler les individus un par un
grâce à leurs faiblesses et vulnérabilités personnelles et individuelles
et s'ils le font à grande échelle
via nos écrans privés
afin que nous ne sachions même pas
ce que les autres citoyens et nos voisins voient,
l'autoritarisme nous enveloppera tel une toile d'araignée
et nous ignorons même que nous sommes dans la toile.
La capitalisation du marché de Facebook
approche le demi milliard de dollars.
C'est parce que c'est une très bonne architecture de persuasion.
Mais la structure de cette architecture
est la même que vous vendiez des chaussures
ou de la politique.
Les algorithmes ne connaissent pas la différence.
Les mêmes algorithmes utilisés sur nous
pour nous rendre plus malléables face aux publicités
organisent aussi nos flux d'informations politiques, personnelles et sociales
et ça doit changer.
Ne vous méprenez pas,
nous utilisons les plateformes numériques car elles ont beaucoup de valeur.
J'utilise Facebook pour garder contact
avec des amis et de la famille à travers le monde.
J'ai écrit sur l'importance des réseaux sociaux pour les mouvements sociaux.
J'ai étudié comment ces technologies peuvent être utilisées
pour contourner la censure à travers le monde.
Ce n'est pas que les dirigeants de Facebook ou Google
essayent perfidement et délibérément
de polariser plus le pays ou le monde
et d'encourager l'extrémisme.
J'ai lu les nombreuses déclarations bien intentionnées
que ces gens ont publiées.
Mais ce n'est pas l'intention ou les déclarations
des gens dans les technologies qui comptent,
ce sont les structures et les modèles commerciaux qu'ils créent.
C'est le cœur du problème.
Soit Facebook est un escroc d'un demi milliard de dollars
et les pubs ne marchent pas sur le site,
ça ne marche pas comme une architecture de persuasion
ou son pouvoir d'influence est très préoccupant.
C'est l'un ou l'autre.
Il en va de même pour Google.
Que pouvons-nous faire ?
Ça doit changer.
Je ne peux pas offrir de recette simple
car nous devons restructurer
tout le fonctionnement de notre technologie numérique.
Tout, de la façon dont la technologie est développée
à la façon dont les incitations, économiques et autres,
sont intégrées au système.
Nous devons faire face et gérer
le manque de transparence créé par les algorithmes propriétaires,
le défi structurel de l'opacité de l'apprentissage des machines,
toutes ces données aveuglément collectées sur nous.
Nous avons devant nous une tâche importante.
Nous devons mobiliser notre technologie,
notre créativité
et oui, notre science politique
pour créer une intelligence artificielle
qui soutient nos objectifs humains
mais qui est aussi contrainte par nos valeurs humaines.
Je comprends que ce ne sera pas simple.
Nous ne serons pas facilement d'accord sur le sens de ces termes.
Mais si nous prenons au sérieux
le fonctionnement de ces systèmes dont nous sommes si dépendants,
je ne vois pas comment nous pouvons encore retarder cette conversation.
Ces structures organisent notre fonctionnement
et elles contrôlent ce que nous pouvons faire ou non.
Beaucoup de ces plateformes financées par les pubs
se proclament gratuites.
Dans ce contexte, ça signifie que nous sommes le produit qui est vendu.
Nous avons besoin d'une économie numérique
où nos données et notre attention
ne sont pas à vendre à l'autoritariste ou au démagogue le plus offrant.
(Applaudissements)
Pour revenir à cette paraphrase hollywoodienne,
nous voulons que le grand pouvoir
de l'intelligence artificielle et de la technologie numérique fleurisse
mais pour ça , nous devons faire face à une grande menace,
les yeux ouverts et maintenant.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)